[موسيقى]
ولا ست
مثل طه
في ال
[موسيقى]
ورى بهذه الاجواء الجميله تحتفل مدينه
صيدا جنوبيه لبنان بالشهر الفضيل مع
الاضواء والزينه التصميم المعماري لخان
الافرنج الذي يعود الى القرن السابع عشر
ما رسم صوره رمضانيه ساحره
ولان رمضان يجمع الاحبه انتشرت جلسات
الالفه من الافطار حتى السحور على واقع
الاناشيد الدينيه مع المسابقات والالعاب
اجواء رائعه جدا والاجواء مع الوضع العام
يعني واحد وقت بيطلع لبرا بفكر غير ما
يفوت لجوه يعني
لبنان ما بده الا روى
نظام بده قوانين الناس تمشي على القوانين
وكل العالم بتكون بالف خير ما بده الا بس
شويه امان وكل العالم بتكون بالف خير
ومبسوطه هيدا الفرح والحياه بس يتركوا له
مجله يعيش ماكولات ومنتوجات وصناعه وحرف
عرضها اصحابها في زوايا الساحه
مدى تخيلي
نشاط مثل هذا بينعمل بصيده كل فتره وياريت
بينعمل على طول لنضلنا ماشيين مرتاحين
كلنا سوا ضروري نكون نحن عم نركز على هذه
الايفنت وغيرها لحتى ننشط فيها اللي
بيشتغلوا من البيوت بيقدروا اكثر يكون عم
ينجوا هذا النشاط نظامه نادي روتراكت
وانتراكت صيدا بالتعاون مع مؤسسه الحرير
للتنميه البشريه المستدامه دعما للقطاع
التربوي نحن اللي عم نقوم فيه هو تحريك
العجل الاقتصاديه يعني الموجودين هون بين
اون لاين بيزنسز وكرافت وصناعه يدويه
عليهم
في هذا النشاط فرح دائم مرادف لشهر رمضان
مهما كان الواقع مرا اضافه الى المنفعه
الاقتصاديه التي تعود بها هكذا نشاطات على
المدينه الا ان الهدف الاساسي يبقى باطفاء
البهجه على الاهالي الذين يحاولون مع
الشهر الفضيل تناسي ازمات بلادهم والدعاء
بان تتلاشى من مدينه صيدا جنوب لبنان ناهد
يوسف العربيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات